hi my name is Devin Reeve and I'm the
one of the producers and the line
producer of a rock and a hard place
how'd you become involved in the project
um while I was friends with James and
James hit me up saying that he was
directing this amazing pilot and we did
a conference call with David and next
thing I know we were prepping the next
day so that's how fast to happen do you
think it's usually happen that fast some
well normally you you'll get hired but
then there's like a week maybe that
there's a downtime before you actually
start your work and prepping for film
but because of the holidays coming up
that we decided to rush it so as soon as
we were hired the next day we were up
and running trying to get everything
ready before the Thanksgiving holiday so
we probably prepped this and about eight
days and so the prep involves what can
you take us from your first step sure
with the prep involves well casting
locked in the script finding your
locations me divine producer doing a
budget allocating money to where it
needs to go
hiring the crew getting all the vendors
set up for therefore the equipment
getting the gear doing a tech Scout
where we all go around to the different
locations and all the departments have a
chance to see everything before they
before we actually start shooting so
they can prep for that location to a
table read and then just a lot of a lot
of detail stuff that has to happen so we
were trying to the original plan was to
shoot this to Monday after the
Thanksgiving holiday where you have
everything those clothes from four days
nothing is open and I was like guys we
have to we can move this to yeah push it
by two days there's no way we can we
will hurt the production if we just go
right into it and and not have those
extra two days to to get everything
ready and thankful thankfully we did
there's a lot of your prep behind the
computer and then once you get here it's
more hands-on it is yeah most most of my
prep is phone calls emails computers
it's basically just call them I call
them the resources that I use over and
over again going hey it's Devon I got
another project this is what I need and
which is once you've done it long enough
you have those relationships a call
which is fantastic
but then again sometimes is you know you
kind of make sure everything comes
within that budget that's been allocated
for a project and depending on there's
any special effects or stunts or animals
or kids you have to take all that into
account which can be a little tricky
sometimes but we always we always pull
it off do you have some sort of template
on your computer that's that it's like a
checklist for you that you work within I
do we have a it's called a
pre-production checklist so we'll know
then we have a giant board and so we'll
start running down what we've done and
checking it off and we'll take the cast
we'll put the cast up on the walls so we
can see who the so we can start
visualizing the cast and seeing how they
match up within the screen within the
story how long have you been doing this
I grew up an actor and probably about 12
years ago I transitioned into producing
as well so now I still act but also
produce and that line produce as well
which kind of covers a broad spectrum
and that I direct every once in a while
so in some music videos a why now but
acting and producing is really the
passion that drives me to stay in this
you